a community ravaged by the lack of
action on the part of our government and
local government state government who
just turned their backs on them what are
we talking about the Sayle of California
it sits between LA and San Francisco and
in that town over the course of two
harrowing days earlier this week
Gustavo Garcia he's a man twice removed
from this country went on what
authorities call a reign of terror so 24
hours shooting spree killing at least
two and injuring many more deputies
taking gunfire from this man 36 year old
Gustavo Garcia and always yell on road
140 and Avenue 256 early Monday morning
you hear the officer reloading his gun
as bullets ring out now while the
circumstances of this are tragic on
their own the run-up to it is even more
so two days before this reign of terror
he was arrested by the - LA County
sheriff's deputies for being under the
influence of a controlled substance he
was held in the county jail for about
ten hours before being released
even though ice officials had issued an
immigration hold on him you see this
arrest wasn't Garcia's first brush of
the law he has a violent criminal past
immigration and customs enforcement
tells Fox 26 News Garcia had been
deported twice in the past the sheriff's
office could have alerted immigration
because of Garcia's extensive rap sheet
which includes armed robbery more than
15 years ago now you might be asking
yourself why did the cops let him go
despite the ice hold he especially given
his past so was it the police's fault
ice did file a detainer as soon as it
learned of Garcia's arrest Friday and
this would be enough to keep him in
custody
in other states but sheriff Boudreaux
says his office no longer recognizes
those detainers and it can't reach out
to ice for misdemeanor crimes till our
County Sheriff Mike Boudreau said before
SB 54 which is the sanctuary state bill
Gustavo Garcia would have been turned
over to ice officials that's how we've
always done it
after SB 54 though we no longer have the
power to do that
we should know the tell our County Board
of Supervisors voted to adopt a
resolution opposing California's
sanctuary state law in May of this year
and even though it's kind of symbolic it
does show a citizenry standing up for
common sense joining me now is to learn
County Sheriff Mike Boudreau sheriff I
know our viewers across the country are
watching this and shaking their heads
going how would how can this happen in
the United States of America where we
emote morning noon and night about the
tragic circumstances of people who are
trying to come into the country and I
get it their tragic circumstances it's
tough but yet the politicians where did
you get a call from Pelosi did you get a
call from you know from Gavin Newsom any
other you know officials in California
concerned about what's happening there
you know the only phone call that I got
was from the ACLU demonizing the actions
that we took which is really unfortunate
you know Tulare County is how it's
pronounced actually but that's Canary
County we are at weird that's fine we're
an agricultural community we produce
multi billion dollars worth of
Agriculture that sent all over the world
and we have a large undocumented
community but we also have a large group
of people who don't commit these types
of crimes on a daily basis I think what
our focus is on is the criminal the
criminal element that ends up in my Jail
that I no longer have the tools to reach
out to ice my counterpart my law
enforcement partners and I'm no longer
able to recognize the detainer through
the sanctuary state law as well as the
ninth court circuit indicating that now
the detainers don't meet due process so
because of those two combined efforts we
no longer can telephone ice and even ask
the question why is this detainer placed
nor can we recognize the detainer itself
and I give a heads-up dice can you give
them a heads-up can you give them a
heads-up can you call say we're about to
release this individual or we have this
individual in custody even if they can't
come and interview him or examine him is
there any notification at all you could
give time we're not allowed to we're not
allowed
to talk to our counterparts under an
outrage
I got to play something me for you
Sheriff this was Nancy Pelosi's claim
about what sanctuary policies actually
accomplished watch our city of San
Francisco is a sanctuary city and we see
it as a place where it makes us safer it
makes us safer because people can can go
to school they can get driver's license
they can be witnesses against other
violence that they see in the community
it's your community feeling safer
tonight they're not feeling safer but I
will say that we don't we're not against
our undocumented community we're not
against immigrants we don't we're not
against dreamers or daca and I think
that it needs to be very clear you know
our community as a whole even our
undocumented community i sat with a
large group of people and they're not
afraid of their law enforcement they're
not even affordable that's why sheriff
that argument that I hear parroted to me
morning noon and night every time we
deal with one of these sanctuary policy
cases we did this in New Jersey a couple
of weeks ago The Advocate that came on
said oh no we're not gonna have
immigrants cooperating with authorities
are not going to show up and testify in
cases that's just bunk but this is the
bet it's her deadline so you don't see
that at all in your community that's not
true we don't see that we see our
community reaching out to us what
they're afraid of what they're afraid of
is that the criminal will return to
their community because we can't report
them to ice
yeah and commit domestic violence rape
burglary robbery other offenses against
property and people Sheriff
thank you for the heads-up and for
speaking out on what we are gonna be
following all throughout the next year
because so many people won't do it we're
going to do it